hospitals across northern China are
filled with families seeking care for
their sick children some are waiting
hours for treatment respiratory viruses
such as influenza and micoplasma
pneumonia a type of bacterial infection
have been spreading for weeks this is
China's first winter in 3 years without
strict covid-19 rules doctors say the
end of pandemic restrictions are largely
to blame during the the covid time
everybody was just sheltered everybody
was sterile in a way sterile so like you
know this kids haven't had any
infections in the past so now that like
they are now mingling in schools and
like you know crowded settings it's as
if they're getting the infections as the
first time so now they are just trying
to build the uh uh the immune system or
antibodies again the World Health
Organization has asked China to provide
more information about the uptic and
respiratory illnesses Beijing says the
Clusters are caused by know pathogens
but the surge has reminded many of the
initial spread of the Corona virus China
was criticized for a lack of
transparency at the beginning of the
pandemic in 2020 it's an association
Chinese officials are determined to
dismiss recently we have seen some
classes of flu cases among children in
China in fact this is very common in
many countries and in China it is under
effective control authorities have urged
Community level healthcare services and
Clinics to work harder this is Beijing
Children's Hospital a top pediatric
facility in the city recently they've
been receiving more than 9,000 patients
every day and have been forced to expand
their capacity and number of
beds this Private Hospital has
temporarily lowered its fees to ease the
demand on public facilities but the
advice across the board is the same
right now that we're seeing surge it's
better to put on the mask again and then
like yeah practice
handwashing though the lockdowns of the
covid-19 pandemic are over doctors here
say many of the habits learned during
that period should be observed again
Katrina U aljazera Beijing